fourteen-year-old Gideon lives with his
family in a small village in eastern
Ghana he heads to the market first thing
every morning every day he spent seven
hours working at this store
he sells kinky fermented cornmeal fast
food he makes himself his parents and
his seven siblings rely on his earnings
in the afternoons he attends school he
wants to get as much as he can from his
lessons public schools are free in Ghana
now but there's a shortage of teaching
materials in a lot of classrooms only
half the books needed are available the
pupils have to pay for school books
themselves and not all of them can
afford it the local library is closed
it's poorly stocked anyway all it has
are a few dog-eared volumes on American
history remnants of donations the
situation is improving thanks to the
charity world Reader students are
getting free e-readers with storage
capacity for up to 4,000 books
the Worldreader nonprofit organization
is helping revolutionize education in
Ghana there's a billion children in the
world currently in the developing world
that don't have an effective education
system there is an enormous amount of
stake here the e-reader and more
importantly the communications with you
either using the telecommunication
technology it's just such a potent
solution to this challenge an e-reader
costs a hundred euros
Worldreader is funded by private
donations and the United Nations
many publishers offer content that can
be downloaded free of charge
it doesn't take students long to get
used to their e-readers books can be
downloaded via the mobile phone network
in just one minute
many Ghanaian schoolchildren are now
reading some 90 books a year according
to the world reader organization I would
like to really do this I'm going to help
my people I'd like to be a barrister I
think I have to read a little to know
about this and people in the future I
will be able to judge people's cases in
a good way so that people would suffer a
readers have been distributed by world
reader in Ghana Kenya and Uganda the
charity is planning to branch out into
South America and Asia next these days
14 year olds Gideon doesn't go anywhere
without his e-reader he spends every
spare minute immersed in a book he'd
like to go to university when he's older
and he'd love to be able to spend all
his time learning but for the time being
reading is still a luxury